eu não sou capaz de médio de média idade
média
outra realidade do meu mundo não tenho
tempo nem dinheiro para trabalhar com
isso é muita desculpa
a história acontece em favela não tinha
água em casa
a experiência em uma favela do rio de
janeiro
claramente no primeiro choque principal
lixo 1
o cheiro de coisa podre no ar
trabalhou no meio desses porcos crianças
porque é muito diferente do slide ver
aqui na foto chocante
porque ali eu aprendi uma outra
realidade não é um outro mundo é o meu
mundo é a minha realidade que tem
pobreza são as crianças do meu mundo que
estão lá
visando gillette buscando no lixo algum
brinquedo para fazer alguma coisa
arranjar alguma diversão porque às vezes
não tem nada ainda seguia com aquela
idade que eu não tenho tempo para nada
porque é muita prova muito trabalho
curso de engenharia civil é muito
difícil ter tempo em rápido quando
começa a conversar com as mulheres nas
comunidades
parece idex é uma história de superação
mais monstro do que a outra é uma coisa
impressionante
são paulo um pouco sobre a jornada de
trabalho dela e da minha e engenharia
tem um futuro promissor
uma senhora de idade que trabalhava de
manhã à noite todo dia limpando o quarto
de motel de 50/60 quarto por noite e de
manhã ela não chegava em casa para
dormir em casa para cuidar das dez
crianças que moravam com ela dormia
quatro horas por dia
quem é que não tem tempo para mudar essa
realidade é dona maria que cuida de
crianças tampouco energia o que a gente
estava começando a trabalhar mais porque
agora ela sai um pouco mais tarde porque
começando a colocar os dados no
computador
ela escrevia o nome dos das pessoas que
chegavam no motel
eu comecei a ficar chocado de que
trabalha tanto e tanto orgulho para
conseguir fazer mais
toda aquela vontade de fazer aquelas
crianças crescerem e se movimentarem é
porque era parte da realidade dela que
aquelas crianças
ela não queria ver os filhos dela e os
filhos da vizinha passando fome
então ela lutava por isso porque a
realidade dela são aquelas crianças são
da minha realidade também não quero ver
os filhos da dona maria passando fome
porque são da minha realidade é minha
realidade elas crianças vão passar fome
então eu voltei agora tentam descobrir o
que eu posso fazer em relação a isso com
o meu papel dentro das favelas dentro
das comunidades mês passado uma
experiência começou a me contar um pouco
mais do que eu posso fazer
interessante que eu entrei no programa
chamado guerreiros sem armas
a gente vai trabalhar numa favela em
santos um agente chegou com um olhar
diferente a gente chegou para buscar a
riqueza buscar as belezas locais de
grafites lindos até alguns detalhes
cuidados uma plantinha bem cuidada todos
os detalhes que transforma aquilo num
melhor lugar do mundo porque a pobreza
as favelas não um lugar horrível de
viver
às vezes tem muita riqueza lá dentro só
que ninguém olha nossa aqui tem muito
pneu que dá para fazer muito brinquedo a
gente chega olha aqui é muito pobre nem
olhava para aquelas crianças brincando
com um monte de lixo estava triste mas é
verdade que elas crianças são
fantásticas porque elas ficavam inovando
e criando brinquedos no meio do lixo
então a gente chegou buscando essas
riquezas e para aprender porque não sou
eu estudante universitário que vai
ensinar a favela como resolver o
problema de pobreza
eles sabem fazer ele tem todo o
conhecimento toda uma experiência de
anos lá dentro construindo isso todos
vão saber fazer histórias em histórias
do mundo para aprender a aprender a
conhecer à comunidade e se reconhecer
porque eles sabem que eles moram
lugar que é pobre eles param às vezes de
que foi reconhecer as riquezas do outro
lado quatro garotas grafites lá é que é
bonito leito olha uma parede linda
fantástica que ele cuida dessa riqueza
porque a comunidade ela tem o poder de
construir seus sonhos e e sérios para
levantar um novo inteiro onde era um ato
conseguiram levantar um novo com ruas
com espaço tudo e quando preciso
conseguir um sonho
então nesse papo nessas conversas
a gente começou a buscar um sonho comum
que une essa comunidade o que é que vai
tirar as pessoas que têm aquelas
discussões políticas e ideológicas lá
dentro o velas para trabalhar junto a
gente vai montando projetos
desenvolvendo um projeto único
mas para não ficar só na conversa
passou três semanas só conversando e
montando reunião chegou a hora de botar
a mão na massa e daí no final do mês
passado algumas semanas atrás a gente
foi para construir o sonho literalmente
nesse momento eles começaram a eles
tomar um choque porque a gente falava
vamos construir vamos fazer a gente
consegue fazer isso é capaz e daí na
hora de levantar um centro comunitário
de dois andares que era um sonho a gente
há quatro dias
eles chegaram a gente olhou e disse tá
aí como é que faz concreto no concreto
de oito anos concreto um sonho de um
parquinho uma área de lazer reforma de
uma quadra era praticamente impossível
fazer em quatro dias o que a comunidade
não fazem 30 anos mas trabalha junto
porque só assim poderá disso a dizer a
gente vai fazer então então vamos fazer
junto e foram vendo as crianças
começaram a tomar conta do espaço delas
foi fantástico porque o bloco e puxando
a corda porque um sozinho e conseguia
todos empoderamento dizendo a gente vai
fazer a gente vai cuidar disso é meu e
foi fantástico porque a gente terminou
o mutirão gente não conseguiu levantar o
centro comunitário e aí não está pronto
os guerreiros no trabalho deles não
terminaram mas centro comunitário nos
guerreiros santos comunitário de theo e
eles começaram a levantar essas paredes
essa falta de duas semanas atrás uma
semana depois de a gente ter terminado
um mutirão não precisavam dos guerreiros
e não precisamos de ninguém
eles já tinham material eles conseguem
com amigos parcerias com prefeituras sim
são possíveis
vai depender de ninguém porque o meu
sonho uma dona maria tinha lá toda
aquela vontade para cuidar dessas
crianças ela não vai esperar ninguém
para cuidar delas ela vai cuidar sozinha
se pra alguém para ajudar é melhor mas
ela não vai parar por causa disso
aqui a gente viu isso e tem um vídeo pra
mim retrata muito esse momento de virada
de chave de dizer que isso é meu e eu
vou construir a história desse vídeo é
que tá acontecendo esse mutirão esse
momento de construção do sonho e chega
um pedido da prefeitura para eles
pararem e daí começa todo o envolvimento
foi ver que o difícil é engajar em que
as pessoas praticamente tinha perdido a
esperança pela vida pelo ser humano era
tudo tão fragmentado que eu perdi um
pouco do sentimento de união que a gente
trabalha tanto é que isso dá um vazio
por alguns instantes por cuidar da gente
estava muito reflexiva sobre por que é
um milagre então é que não é a
construção de uma coisa física
eu estava me deixando um pouco
angustiada eu quero muito ver o milagre
acontecer eu reparei que ela tem uma
movimentação e sabe quem é que vai ficar
responsável junto com o jovem chegou
naquele dia e até agora não vai dar nada
você mandou parar a nossa população aqui
nós continuamos dinho e eu vi que você
não gostaria que tirasse o trabalho
junto às crianças
o game não falar mas na minha visão a
gente atua como canal 13 entender o
poder deles como um grupo como eles
podem transformar que começa a botar um
bico de luz e vai levantar isso aqui que
eu vou fazer história e ansiosa a
geração a geração que a tecnologia
brasileira
isso nunca pode acontecer na história a
gente roda o mundo mas a gente também a
geração as maiores responsabilidades que
já existiram
eu ouvi isso da boca do secretário geral
das nações unidas para a gente disse
não sou eu vai mudar essa realidade não
sou eu tenho potencial de mudar isso
poderá dar a gente não pode esperar
dessa pressa porque a primeira geração
que pode solucionar a pobreza no mundo
faz parte da nossa realidade é a nossa
realidade mulheres hoje à noite de novo
trabalhando ela e volta é capaz que eu
não posso fazer isso me dói me convidar
vocês
para sair hoje daqui com determinação
para sair do texas em adubo e com
vontade e determinação
aquela vontade de a gente vai construir
o barracão
a gente vai cuidar dessas crianças vamos
levantar diferente
obrigado